[Music]
very nice hey what's up my name is Frank
I'm a New York City firefighter I work
in a lot of ten and I'm a lot of ten
truck chauffeur what's up man my name is
man Clark I am a seven year veteran at
the Trenton Fire Department I'm Michael
my anko I'm lieutenant and hooking
ladder company for the city Glen Cove
volunteer fire department anytime that
there's any kind of emergency we're
typically the first people who respond a
large part of our our job is community
involvement in engagement just being
present making real connections with
people it's the best job in the world
because helping people it's like one of
the biggest benefits you can always like
have you know being a fine that it's
like my second family they're all about
taking care of each other and you know
it's a brotherhood like you know we live
together we eat together we sleep
together and you take care of one
another and the things that we have as a
unit I have three commitments to my
people everybody who clocks in will also
clock out everybody gets a fair shake
and no one and I mean no one gets left
behind when it comes to skin care I get
faces on the outside and I'm not telling
to find them and I get crushed fire so I
mean the least you tell them that better
off you are
so what WI having skin care
conversations so I think the interaction
was pretty authentic the scene looks
like a hotel resort I don't know if our
house nullify us definitely not mine hey
everybody I'm Rob Lowe from 911 I want
to thank you all for all that you do for
our communities and as a reward I'm
hoping that you enjoy your spa day
god bless use it in health safety and
unhappiness
that's actually really I'm all-in
experience for me no set foot in one
although you need an hour he's gonna
need about 12
we head downtown to the four seasons
they greeted as well we were escorted
upstairs to the spa area
I think these rules make me wanna floss
jump into a whole different world we
come into the lounge and we have these
nice juicy cheeseburgers with onions on
top of it and the nice french fries and
once you see that on the plate you know
you're in for a great treat the rest of
the day I got a pedicure
and it was amazing she filed down my
nails and gave me a foot massage
it was completely relaxing like this is
my first time ever having like a real
professional massage I'm feeling just
amazing right now
the hot rocks the oil smells everything
it was great it really made me feel so
much better
I think the massage was like changing
she began to do an oil infused scalp
massage which was something I'd never
experienced or you know wasn't born fine
then you know you learn how to be a fine
and you know but you know for anybody
it's still scary you know I mean it's
real life you know and then you homie
you think about your children and you're
like you know you want to make it home
at the end of the night but also you
want to your job you know your job is to
protect the people of the city of New
York the fire service in general is no
longer just guys running around with
exes we literally do almost everything
as far as emergencies are considered I'm
a hazardous materials tech I am a Rescue
Diver
we also are emergency responder it is a
definitely a very stressful job if you
don't have the proper outlets a lot of
us on our jobs
you know we forget about ourselves and
you know take care ourselves probably
should maybe almost come first because
we don't take care of ourselves how are
we gonna go out and protect other people
get to me like when you feel good about
yourself you look good you feel good you
just perform better in anything you do
in life you know running around never
really having time for yourself because
you're always thinking about somebody
else you know it really is nice to have
something done for you taking care of
yourself pampering yourself a little bit
so thanks Rob Lowe thanks nan one lone
star for this great opportunity captain
she ate it my favorite part today was
getting to know both of you guys and
what you do in the fire service in his
Jersey and what you do in the fire
service on Long Island but honestly I'm
really blessed to meet every one of
these guys they're honestly real good
people and as silly as it sounds they
are heroes don't miss the two night
premier of 9-1-1 Lone Star Sunday
January 19th only on Fox
[Music]
you
[Music]